bruce arians and i mentioned this
last hour probably because i didn't peek
ahead on the outline and realize we're
covering it coming up but that's not the
first time nor the last that that will
happen bruce erin's talking about
antonio brown's workload and i mentioned
it again his pitch count was a little
higher than we anticipated we tried to
go two minutes early in the ball game to
get some life so his pitch count was up
a little bit he handled it well he did
everything we that he needed to do to
play well in the game the guys embraced
and they helped him yada yada but the
bottom line is he wants it to go down
this week he wants the number to go down
he was third behind
chris goblin with 47 snaps mike evans
with 43.
brown had 39. scotty miller's the guy
who got the short straw
scotty miller only had 19 snaps and and
it goes back to that
that push and pull that i still think is
there yeah i don't think bruce arians
ever wanted him
bruce erians finally gave in
but bruce arians isn't the kind of guy
especially at this age who's going to
let something go
and there may have been some i told you
so
being spoken behind the scenes and maybe
the frustration with having to use
antonio brown as much as he did maybe
that is what caused aryans to
to call out tom brady in kind of a
indirect and also as you said earlier
this week misguided way that maybe mike
evans wasn't as wide open as bruce
arians is suggesting but aryans is just
maybe irritated with how this has gone i
mean think about it they were putting
together
this this beautiful
sculpture and it got smashed by the
saints right in one night and now
they're going to go back to the drawing
board to a certain extent they got to
figure out how to do it with this
expectation that antonio brown
is going to be on the field and going to
have the ball thrown as well yeah i mean
listen this is this is the risk they
took
certainly you know and they within that
risk they you know took a shot because
of it last week you know they got away
from what they've done and what made
them well i mean he could talk about
yeah we tried to get his two minutes
early in the game but i mean it started
out with antonio brown on the field you
know this is three receivers and you
could tell just from the get-go the plan
was oh
you know and i don't think it was like a
forced antonio brown thing i do think
they looked at it and then they had a
match-up against the saints where they
said hmm this team
will play us in some man-to-man and i
don't think they can match up so i don't
think they just did it just like tom
wanted it and all that but i think they
got a little infatuated with the thought
of it that would be my take from it more
than anything but you know what did it
lead to
it led to the offense never getting in
rhythm the offensive line never you know
establishing any physicality or control
of the line of scrimmage at all and
really in the best games we've seen all
year from tampa bay
it's been
a pretty balanced attack with yeah not
that it always has to be a 100 yard
rusher but somebody flirting with those
type of numbers and then within those
that's when brady's really struck down
field for big passes the real the chunk
plays 30 40 yard passes
you know again i think what you saw too
a little bit was the other night was
you know the brady and new england
offense and then i think we also saw the
brady and new england type play where
it's like if he's in shotgun he's just
not going to stand in there and wait for
some of the more aggressive throws down
the field you know but
what i've seen and what i've been saying
on my podcast and things like that when
you keep an extra tight end and block
and do those things he takes like a deep
breath and he lets plays develop down
the field just feeling a little bit
better that he's got that one or two
extra guys to protect him and then he
throws strikes so that to me would be
the thing i'd go get back to that's the
best buccaneers team and offense i see
when they play that style of football
they ran the ball
five times right which was the lowest in
any game
in the history
of the league that's amazing chris
unbelievable they broke the record
brenton's not the record you want to
break they broke the record set by the
vikings who had six rushing attempts and
a 27-6 loss to the bills in josh allen's
rookie year just kind of a weird
smackdown
right and one of the reasons you abandon
the run so early is when you get down so
early there's no point
but uh the patriots have only five runs
and one of them was a kneel down so they
had only four runs
for the game no i mean the buccaneers i
keep doing that a lot of people do
because i think tom brady still plays
for the patriots a lot of people i still
do it remember earlier this year when
the patriots were getting ready to play
the broncos i'm thinking right they just
played that was the buccaneers that had
played the broncos so i can't i can't
get away from it after 20 years can't
get away from it uh anyway the
buccaneers had five rushing attempts and
the buccaneers need to establish
themselves against the panthers they
need to avoid falling into that trap and
maybe they need to have antonio brown on
the sideline more but that's going to
create a problem because and this is why
i didn't like the contract he signed
incentives tied to catches yards and
touchdowns if you're not on the field
you're not making that money and at some
point if you're antonio brown you're
going to be pissed yeah yeah no i you're
right i mean when it is about money and
it's about you got to play and get
numbers and stats and things like that
they're they're flirting with danger
again they are you know that there's no
doubt about that but
i you know
again i think with brady's influence
with antonio brown
and the fact that antonio brown has to
realize he's got to be careful because
if he causes an issue with this football
team with what we all perceive as his
best football angel on his shoulder
friend now tom brady if he can't make it
work there he will scare off everybody
else so that's the one thing they got
going for them and we'll see where it
goes but yeah i don't expect to see him
on the field nearly as much this week
one of the biggest challenges for the
rational mind is to predict the
reactions of the irrational mind that's
the problem yeah
we can say
that antonio brown should react this way
should react that way based upon the
body of work we've seen from antonio
brown for the last two years the
rational mind cannot accurately predict
what he may do
if he finds himself neutralized if
he detects as we detect that there's a
tug of war happening between tom brady
and bruce arians and he's caught in the
middle we can't accurately forecast how
that's going to affect his behavior and
he could reach a breaking point far
sooner than the rational person would so
that's why this is all something we're
talking about and watching very closely
because it could blow
really at any time especially after the
ugliness that we saw on sunday night by
the total buccaneers organization
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports